I think chalkboard is much more nature
for the students in their form ears
because if I write all the equations on
the slides first of all all those
equations appear at the same time and
and so so it is actually harder for the
students to follow the logic between
formulas and in my feeling is that it is
so much natural to see all those
equations popping up in a logical
sequence for them and by writing down
then on the chalkboard people have time
to sink as well what is actually
happening and I have also the freedom to
point to the red urban equation on the
board slowly so that people everybody
who is not very familiar with the
mathematics can follow factorial x
squared plus 3 triple prime 0 divided by
3 factorial X plus infinite number of
times and we 0 is the position of where
you have minimap so I think that is your
decision to use chalkboard in
combination with slides do to my slides
content information which is actually
already covered from the previous
lecture so that's a purpose to fresh
through the information which is
actually already covered during the last
few lectures to remind people that ok
you have learned this before right and
so so I don't have to waste a lot of
time to copy then on the chalkboard
because they already learned that and
secondly I can use slides to include
interesting figures interesting videos
interesting pictures etc so that
actually that is complementary to my
chalkboard teaching style